[Musique]
le procureur molas nous dit sereinement
si je puis dire en 2018
vingt détenus islamistes radicaliser
vont être libérés en 2019
vont être libérés les 40 sont des
dangers pour la société française
les 40 et ils vont être libérés
alors que nous venons d'assister à liège
à ce que nous avons assisté ce matin
monsieur le premier ministre
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que
l'arsenal pénal français doit être
renforcée parce que la sécurité de nos
concitoyens
le vaut bien la parole à monsieur le
premier ministre je suis convaincu
monsieur le sénateur et vous avez exercé
des responsabilités éminentes que en
matière de sécurité ça n'est ni la
communication ni même nécessairement
l'arsenal législatif qui sont les plus
utiles mais l'efficacité opérationnelle
l'efficacité opérationnelle aujourd'hui
elle passe notamment par plus de moyens
affectés au terrain par plus de
policiers par plus de gendarmes ce que
nous sommes engagés un exercice et un
effort de la nation dans lequel nous
sommes engagés avec 10000 recrutant
10000 recrutement dans le quinquennat
dont 1900 dont 1900 serviront à étoffer
les effectifs de la dsi compte tenu des
effectifs que j'ai mentionné les vins de
2018 et les 22000 19
nous sommes parfaitement en mesure de
fournir cet effort le problème n'est pas
uniquement dans la force ou dans la
présence
il est vous l'avez dit aussi dans la loi
fait avancer la loi fait bouger la loi
il est évident qu'il faut bouger sur la
consultation des sites jihadistes il est
évident qu'il faut bouger sur le fait
qu'un lien avec une organisation
terroriste
ça doit être considérée comme une
intelligence avec l'ennemi
l'an passé avec la procédure apb plus de
80 % des lycéens avaient reçu une
réponse favorable leurs voeux dès les
premiers jours
aujourd'hui avec parcours sup seuls 24%
des candidats ont accepté définitivement
une proposition et 13000 personnes ont
déjà été éliminées du dispositif les
taux d'échec important dans les lycées
des communes populaires montre qu'une
sélection sociale est à l'oeuvre de
nombreuses familles sont choqués par le
caractère souvent incompréhensibles et
erratique des résultats à monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple
à quel contrôle de légalité avez-vous
soumis les procédures mises en oeuvre
par les universités pour sélectionner
les dossiers
pouvez-vous garantir aux familles que
ses algorithmes locaux n'utilise aucun
traitement automatisé
ni aucun processus aléatoire vous avez
publié l'algorithme nationale parcours
sup
vous devez maintenant rendre publiques
ses algorithmes locaux comme le sénat
vous l'a demandé à l'unanimité
ouais ce que je partage avec vous c'est
le sort des élèves qui attendent encore
ce matin j'étais dans le 19ème
arrondissement arrondissements
populaires où j'ai été élu à l'assemblée
nationale j'étais avec des lycéens et je
leur ai demandé au terminal ceux qui
avaient reçu une proposition un sur deux
avait déjà reçu une proposition dans la
filière de son choix
vous parlez de la transparence jamais
aucun gouvernement n'a été aussi
transparent
trois éléments le premier élément c'est
sur les critères sur les critères que
chaque formation sur les critères que
les êtres humains que la communauté
pédagogique de chaque formation a décidé
d'appliquer pour prioriser les dossiers
ces critères ils ont été rendus publics
dès la mise en ligne de parcours sup
ensuite nous avons lu nous avons voulu
rendre encore plus transparent le
processus complet et c'est l'ouverture
que nous avons menées
[Musique]